So today we have a story that we think might make you believe something that right now you do not believe. And to tell that story, I'm joined here in the studio by NPR science reporters Alix Spiegel and Lulu Miller. Hey there, guys.
今天我们要讲一个故事，我们认为它可能会让你相信一些你目前还不相信的事情。为了讲述这个故事，NPR科学记者Alix Spiegel和Lulu Miller来到了演播室。你们好。
Hi.
你好。
Hello.
And do I have this right? So you bought a rat, and you brought it to NPR headquarters in Washington, DC?
我没理解错吧？你们买了一只老鼠，然后把它带到了位于华盛顿特区的NPR总部？
We did.
是的。
Alix bought the rat.
是Alix买的老鼠。
I did.
是我买的。
And where at NPR did you bring the rat to?
你们把老鼠带到NPR的什么地方了？
We ferreted it into a little kind of edit booth type thing--
我们把它偷偷带进了一个类似编辑间的小隔间里——
[GIGGLING]
[笑声]
Hi, buddy!
嗨，小家伙！
--type office. And we invited people into the room one by one.
——这种办公室。然后我们把人一个个请进房间。
So can you just describe what we got here?
你能描述一下我们当时的情况吗？
It's a rat.
那是一只老鼠。
Pinkish ears.
粉红色的耳朵。
Red eyes.
红眼睛。
Long nose.
长鼻子。
And sat them down in front of this rat and asked this question.
我们让他们坐在那只老鼠面前，问了这个问题。
Do you think that the thoughts that you have in your head-- OK, the private thoughts that you have in your head-- could influence how that rat moves through space?
你认为你脑子里的想法——我是说，你脑子里那些私人的想法——会影响这只老鼠在空间中的移动吗？
No.
不会。
And it was almost unanimous. People did not believe that their personal thoughts would have any effect on the rat at all.
几乎众口一词。人们根本不相信他们的个人想法会对老鼠产生任何影响。
Because that would suggest some sort of telepathy which I don't have.
因为那意味着某种我并不具备的隔空取物或心灵感应。
And Ira, maybe that's what you think too.
Ira，也许你也是这么想的。
That is what I think. I don't think that people thinking thoughts will affect a rat's behavior.
我确实是这么想的。我不认为人的想法会影响老鼠的行为。
Well, you're wrong.
嗯，你错了。
No.
不。
(CHUCKLING) Yes.
（轻笑）是的。
OK, so who's this?
好吧，他是谁？
This is a man named Bob Rosenthal. He's a research psychologist. And early in his career, he did this thing. He went into his lab late at night and hung signs on all of the rat cages. And some of the signs said that the rat in the cage was incredibly smart. And some of the signs said that the rat in the cage was incredibly dumb, even though neither of those things was true.
这是一个叫Bob Rosenthal的人。他是一位研究心理学家。在他职业生涯早期，他做了这样一件事。他深夜走进实验室，在所有的鼠笼上贴了标签。有些标签写着笼子里的老鼠非常聪明，有些标签写着笼子里的老鼠非常笨，尽管这两者都不是真的。
They were very average rats that you would buy from a research institute that sells rats for a living.
它们只是你从卖老鼠的研究机构买来的非常普通的实验鼠。
So then Bob brings this group of experimenters into his lab, and he says, for the next week, some of you are going to get these incredibly smart rats. And some of you are going to get these incredibly stupid rats. And your job is to run your rat through a maze and record how well it does.
然后Bob把这群实验人员带进实验室，他说，接下来的一周，你们中的一些人将获得这些极其聪明的老鼠，另一些人将获得这些极其愚蠢的老鼠。你们的工作是让你们的老鼠跑迷宫，并记录它的表现。
Can you just pick up the rat?
你能把那只老鼠拿起来吗？
So, Ira, we actually did a very lo-fi, unscientific version of this in that little room in NPR.
所以，Ira，我们实际上在NPR的那个小房间里做了一个非常低配、不科学的版本。
They let you do that?
他们让你这么做？
We didn't ask permission.
我们没问过许可。
Is that OK to do?
这样做没问题吗？
Yeah.
可以。
And you've probably already guessed where this is going.
你可能已经猜到结果会怎样了。
Yeah. In Bob's real study, the experimenters ran the rats that they had been told were smart.
是的。在Bob的真实研究中，实验人员运行了那些被告知很聪明的实验鼠。
She has sort of an intelligent looking face.
她长着一张看起来很聪明的脸。
And the rats they had been told were dumb.
还有那些被告知很笨的老鼠。
Yeah, he seems kind of lazy.
是的，他看起来有点懒。
It was not even close.
差距非常大。
The results were so dramatic.
结果太惊人了。
In Bob's real study, the smart rats did almost twice as well as the dumb rats.
在Bob的真实研究中，聪明组老鼠的表现几乎是笨拙组的两倍。
Wait, even though they were the same?
等等，即使它们本质上是一样的？
Yeah, even though the smart rats were not smart and the dumb rats were not dumb. They were all just the same average kind of lab rat. It was so shocking, people didn't really believe him.
是的，尽管聪明的老鼠并不聪明，笨的老鼠也不笨。它们都只是普通种类的实验鼠。这太令人震惊了，人们甚至不太相信他。
I was having trouble publishing any of this.
我当时很难发表这些研究成果。
And so what was going on? Like, what was actually happening to make the rats do this?
那么到底发生了什么？是什么导致老鼠表现出这种差异？
So what Bob figured out was that the expectations that the experimenters carried in their heads subtly changed the way that the experimenters touched the rats, and that changed the way that the rats behaved. So when the experimenters thought that the rats were really smart, they felt more warmly towards the rats. And so they touched them more gently.
Bob发现，实验人员脑中携带的期望细微地改变了他们触摸老鼠的方式，而这改变了老鼠的行为。当实验人员认为老鼠很聪明时，他们对老鼠的感觉更温暖，所以他们触摸老鼠时更温柔。
We do know that handling rats and handling them more gently can actually increase the performance of rats.
我们确实知道，接触老鼠并更温柔地对待它们，实际上可以提高老鼠的表现。
And how does this play out when it comes to people? How do our expectations of other people work?
那么这在人身上是怎么体现的呢？我们对他人的期望是如何起作用的？
Well, what you saw in the rats totally holds for people too. I talked to Carol Dweck, who's a psychologist and researcher at Stanford.
嗯，你在老鼠身上看到的，完全适用于人类。我采访了斯坦福大学的心理学家和研究员Carol Dweck。
You may be standing farther away from someone you have lower expectations for. You may not be making as much eye contact. And it's not something you can put your finger on. We are not usually aware of how we are conveying our expectations to other people. But it's there.
你可能会与你期望较低的人站得更远，你可能不会进行那么多的眼神交流。这不是你能明确指出来的事。我们通常不会意识到我们是如何向他人传达我们的期望的，但它确实存在。
And it happens in all kinds of areas. Research has shown that a teacher's expectations can raise or lower a student's IQ score, that a mother's expectations influences the drinking behavior of her middle schooler, that military trainers' expectations can literally make a soldier run faster or slower. So my question was-- you know, how far does this go?
这种情况发生在各种领域。研究表明，老师的期望可以提高或降低学生的智商分数；母亲的期望会影响初中生的饮酒行为；军事教练的期望甚至能让士兵跑得更快或更慢。所以我的问题是——这到底能走多远？
So Carol, clearly these expectation effects exist on a continuum. So for example, if I expect that if somebody jumps off a building, they will be able to fly, that's not going to work out so well, right?
Carol，显然这些期望效应存在于一个连续体上。例如，如果我期望某人从楼上跳下去就能飞起来，那肯定行不通，对吧？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
So what does science know about where we should draw the line? Does it have a clear sense of that?
那么科学界是否知道我们应该在哪里划清界限？有没有明确的定义？
No. That line is moving. As we come to understand things that are possible and mechanisms through which a belief affects an outcome or one person affects another person, that line can move.
没有。那条界限是在移动的。随着我们逐渐理解什么是可能的，以及信念影响结果或人影响人的机制，那条界限就会移动。
Well, from WBEZ, Chicago, it's This American Life . Today on our program, we have a kind of hard to believe example of what expectations can do to people. This story is from a new radio show and podcast that Alix and Lulu are launching this week. It's called Invisibilia . It's about the invisible forces that shape human behavior, like beliefs and assumptions and emotions, which I know sounds a little abstract. But in execution, I have to say it is anything but.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。今天我们的节目中，有一个关于期望如何影响人的、令人难以置信的例子。这个故事来自Alix和Lulu本周推出的一档新广播节目和播客，名叫《无形》（Invisibilia）。它讲述的是塑造人类行为的隐形力量，比如信念、假设和情绪，我知道这听起来有点抽象。但说到执行，我必须说它一点也不抽象。
Alix used to work here at our program. Lulu worked at Radiolab , and their new show is sort of halfway between the two. A quick heads-up before they launch into this. As you may have noticed, their voices sound a lot alike.
Alix过去曾在我们的节目组工作，Lulu曾在《Radiolab》工作，她们的新节目介于两者之间。在她们开始之前提醒一下，你可能已经注意到了，她们的声音听起来非常像。
They are.
确实如此。
Sorry. Yeah.
抱歉，是的。
Yes, I know that is not news to the two of you at all. So stay with us. And Lulu, let's just jump right in. Where do you want to start?
是的，我知道这对你们俩来说不是什么新闻。那么，请继续关注。Lulu，我们直接开始吧。你想从哪里开始？
Well, I'll start with a question that I asked the rat scientist, the expectations guy, Bob Rosenthal.
好吧，我先问一个我问过老鼠科学家、那位“期望先生”Bob Rosenthal的问题。
OK.
好的。
Could my expectations make a blind person who literally has no eyeballs see?
我的期望能让一个根本没有眼球的盲人看见东西吗？
No way. The expectations will not make him see.
绝不可能。期望不会让他看见。
How sure are you about that one?
你对此有多确定？
Positive.
非常确定。
So I'm deep in the woods of Southern California with a man named Daniel Kish. We've been hiking for hours, climbing over tree stumps and along the edges of a steep ravine. And we're just sitting down in the dirt to take a break.
我现在正和一位叫Daniel Kish的男人深处南加州的树林里。我们已经徒步了好几个小时，爬过树桩，沿着陡峭峡谷的边缘行走。我们坐在泥地上休息。
Could we look at your eyes?
我们能看看你的眼睛吗？
In terms of them being out?
你是说把假眼拿出来？
Yeah.
对。
好的。
And then Daniel pulls down his lower eyelids--
然后Daniel拉下他的下眼睑——
Let me just--
让我——
--and removes his eyes. They're prosthetic, of course, and they clink a little bit as he hands them over to me.
——取出了他的眼睛。当然，那是假体，当他递给我时，它们发出轻微的撞击声。
That's so cool.
太酷了。
Two of the most beautiful hazel-blue eyes I've ever seen in the palm of his hand.
这是我在他手心里见过的最美丽的榛蓝色眼睛。
Can I hold them?
我可以拿着它们吗？
Yeah.
可以。
OK. Is it OK if my hand--
好的，我的手可以——
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Wow. They are so lifelike. Does it feel odd to not have them in?
哇。它们太逼真了。把它们拿出来感觉怪怪的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Oh, it does?
哦，是吗？
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
OK.
好的。
Daniel's eyes had to be removed when he was just a toddler because of cancer.
Daniel在幼儿时期因为癌症不得不摘除眼球。
Retinoblastoma, which is basically eye cancer.
视网膜母细胞瘤，基本就是眼癌。
And yet he's the one who's led me on this hike deep into the woods. We get to forks in the road, and he knows they're there. He leads me across a footbridge that's maybe two and a half feet wide without slowing down.
然而，是他带领我在这片树林里进行了这次徒步。我们遇到路口，他知道路在那里。他带领我穿过一座只有两英尺半宽的人行天桥，没有减速。
I think we've passed what I was looking for.
我想我们已经过了我要找的地方。
And over and over, the path takes us right alongside the edge of a cliff. And Daniel gets within inches but always senses it. So how does he do it? Well, he's got a cane and a hiking stick. But mainly--
而且一次又一次，小路带我们走在悬崖边上。Daniel离边缘只有几英寸，但他总是能感知到。那么他是怎么做到的呢？嗯，他有一根手杖和一根登山杖。但主要是——
[TONGUE CLICKING]
[舌头点击声]
--he clicks.
——他点击。
You press the tongue on the roof of the mouth.
你用舌头按压上颚。
Is it kind of like [TONGUE CLICKING]?
是像这样[舌头点击声]吗？
You're creating a vacuum.
你在制造真空。
Huh.
嗯。
He clicks with his tongue as a way of understanding where he is in space. This is basically what bats do. Echolocation, the scientists call it. It's like sonar. From the way those clicks bounce off of things in the environment, Daniel gets a sort of sonic representation of what's around him.
他用舌头发出的咔嗒声来了解自己在空间中的位置。这基本上就是蝙蝠所做的。科学家称之为回声定位。这就像声纳。通过那些咔嗒声在环境中物体上反弹的方式，Daniel得到了他周围环境的某种声音表征。
So here, [TONGUE CLICKING], I can sense trees poking up.
就像这里，[舌头点击声]，我能感觉到树木凸出来。
Now, Daniel just happened to intuitively invent this when he was a toddler. No one taught him or trained him. He just made it up. And since he's been doing it his whole life, he's now so good at it that he can tell all sorts of things about what's in front of him-- if there's a wall, if the vegetation is dense or sparse.
Daniel是在幼儿时期直觉地发明了这一点的。没有人教他或训练他。他只是自己想出来的。由于他一生都在这样做，他现在已经非常擅长了，以至于他能分辨出面前物体的各种信息——是否有墙壁，植被是茂密还是稀疏。
So here's a bench.
这里有个长椅。
Yep.
没错。
Garbage bins.
垃圾桶。
Ding, ding, ding.
叮，叮，叮。
Outhouse.
厕所。
Wow.
哇。
And not only does this allow him to hike--
这不仅让他能够徒步——
So we'll go this way.
我们往这边走。
--navigate foreign cities alone, rock climb, horseback ride, but the one that gets all the attention is that he can ride a bicycle.
——独自在陌生的城市穿行、攀岩、骑马，但最引人注目的是他能骑自行车。
Meet Daniel Kish. He's blind, but that doesn't stop him from riding his bike.
见见Daniel Kish。他是盲人，但这并不能阻止他骑自行车。
You may have heard of Daniel Kish before.
你可能以前听说过Daniel Kish。
Daniel Kish is completely blind.
Daniel Kish是完全失明的。
He's usually called the Batman.
他通常被称为“蝙蝠侠”。
This real life Batman--
这位现实生活中的蝙蝠侠——
Because he is the man who clicks, like a bat.
因为他是那个像蝙蝠一样发出咔嗒声的人。
His remarkable, bat-like abilities.
他非凡的、像蝙蝠一样的能力。
And he has made the media rounds to demonstrate what is usually described as his most amazing--
他已经在媒体上演示过通常被描述为他最令人惊叹的——
Extraordinary.
非凡的。
Phenomenal.
惊人的。
Remarkable.
了不起的。
--nearly superhuman ability of being able to ride a bicycle even though he is blind.
——近乎超人的能力，即尽管他是盲人，却能骑自行车。
As you watch him, remember, he can't see a thing.
当你看着他时，记住，他什么也看不见。
A narrative that Daniel thinks is all wrong.
Daniel认为这种叙述是完全错误的。
(SINGING) Dee, dee, dee, dee, dee, dee, dee, dee. Step right up! Step right up! The amazing Daniel Kish will demonstrate one of his greatest tricks to date.
（唱歌）迪，迪，迪，迪，迪，迪，迪，迪。快来，快来！了不起的Daniel Kish将演示他迄今为止最伟大的技巧之一。
This is Daniel's buddy Brian Bushway, who has had to watch his poor friend wheel out the old bicycle so many times for the media that he couldn't help but mock the whole set up when I asked him to do it for me.
这是Daniel的好友Brian Bushway，他看着他可怜的朋友为了媒体一遍又一遍地推出那辆旧自行车，当我请他为我展示时，他忍不住嘲笑了整个场面。
And then he will proceed to mount himself on a bike and ride.
然后他将继续骑上自行车并骑行。
And though Daniel indulged, pulling figure eights and riding beautifully as I ran beside him with my microphone, the two of them made it clear that my amazement was kind of offensive.
虽然Daniel还是配合了，在我的麦克风跟随下表演了“8”字骑行，骑得非常漂亮，但他们俩都很清楚，我的惊叹其实有点冒犯。
So step right up, step right up, and see the amazing Daniel Kish do something that everybody can, but most people don't.
所以快来，快来，看看了不起的Daniel Kish做一些每个人都能做，但大多数人却不去做的事。
And here's where we get back to expectations. See, Daniel thinks there is nothing amazing about him. He thinks that most blind people who don't have other disabilities could do things like ride bikes.
这就是我们回到期望的地方。你看，Daniel认为他自己没有什么了不起的。他认为大多数没有其他残疾的盲人都能像骑自行车这样。
I definitely think that most blind people could move around with fluidity and confidence if that were the expectation.
我绝对认为，如果抱有这种期望，大多数盲人都能带着流利和自信四处走动。
See, he thinks the reason that more blind people don't isn't just because they haven't learned to click. But it's because the expectations that you or I are carrying around in our own heads about what blind people can do are simply way too low.
你看，他认为更多的盲人不这样做，不仅仅是因为他们没有学会点击，而是因为你或我脑中携带的关于盲人能做什么的期望，实在是太低了。
They wouldn't be able to hike. They wouldn't be able to run. They wouldn't be able to engage in manual labor.
他们将无法徒步，无法奔跑，无法从事体力劳动。
Daniel, like Bob, thinks those expectations, those private thoughts in our heads, are extremely powerful things, because over time, they have the ability to change the blind person we are thinking about.
Daniel像Bob一样，认为那些期望，那些我们脑中的私密想法，是非常强大的东西，因为随着时间的推移，它们有能力改变我们正在思考的那个盲人。
That psychology becomes inculcated in the blind person, absorbed and translated into physical reality.
这种心理会渗入盲人的意识中，被吸收并转化为物理现实。
And so Daniel thinks if we could all change our expectations of what blind people are capable of, then not only would you see a lot more blind people on bikes, but--
所以Daniel认为，如果我们都能改变我们对盲人能力的期望，那么你不仅会看到更多的盲人骑自行车，而且——
More blind people could--
更多的盲人可以——
--in a very real way--
——以一种非常真实的方式——
--see.
——看见。
Yeah, he just said "see."
是的，他刚才说了“看见”。
It's actually pretty simple and straightforward.
这实际上非常简单直接。
And it turns out neuroscientists are looking into this idea and seeing some pretty shocking results. And we'll get there. But first, to understand what Daniel means, how expectations could give a blind person vision, we need to first see how Daniel himself shot through this forcefield of low expectations, a story which starts back in 1967, when Daniel was 13 months old, and that second eyeball had just been removed.
事实证明，神经科学家们正在研究这个想法，并看到了一些非常惊人的结果。我们稍后会讲到。但首先，为了理解Daniel的意思，即期望如何能赋予盲人视觉，我们首先需要看看Daniel自己是如何穿透这些低期望的力场的，这个故事始于1967年，当时Daniel才13个月大，他的第二只眼球刚刚被摘除。
Oh, my gosh.
我的天哪。
This is Danielle's mother, Paulette Kish. And a few days after taking her son home from the hospital, Paulette realized she was facing a really difficult choice.
这是Daniel的母亲Paulette Kish。在带着儿子从医院回家的几天后，Paulette意识到她正面临一个非常艰难的选择。
My mom thought that I should put him in cotton.
我妈妈认为应该把他装在棉花里。
Cotton?
棉花？
Wrap him in cotton so that he didn't get hurt, so that he was so protected. That's really how she felt.
把他裹在棉花里，这样他就不会受伤，这样他就很受保护。她确实是这样想的。
See, Daniel was a very rambunctious little guy.
你看，Daniel是一个非常吵闹的小家伙。
He started climbing when he was six months old, before he even walked.
他在六个月大、还没学会走路时就开始攀爬了。
And that didn't change when he went blind.
即便在他失明后也没有改变。
We had bookshelves he would climb, so I'd have to move everything off the bookshelves, because he would get into them.
我们有书架，他会爬上去，所以我不得不把书架上的所有东西都搬走，因为他会钻进去。
So Paulette needed to decide, was her mom right? Was it time to start putting some restrictions on him, or was she going to raise him like a seeing child, allow him to explore his world with very few restrictions on him for blindness? And Paulette went with option two. She was going to banish her fear.
所以Paulette需要决定，她妈妈是对的吗？是时候开始对他施加一些限制了，还是她要像对待视力正常的孩子那样抚养他，让他以极少的关于失明的限制去探索世界？Paulette选择了第二种方案。她要驱逐内心的恐惧。
Just put it away. In the beginning, I think that's what I did. I just put it away.
只是把它抛开。在最初，我想我就是这么做的。我只是把它抛开了。
And so, when two police officers showed up at her door--
所以，当两名警察出现在她家门口——
Two big, huge police officers holding my child.
两个又高又大的警察抱着我的孩子。
--having picked up Daniel for climbing the fence into their neighbor's yard--
——因为Daniel爬过栅栏进了邻居院子而被警察捡到——
You can't let him do that. He could fall.
你不能让他这么做。他可能会摔倒。
--Paulette felt their same worries--
——Paulette感受到了他们同样的担忧——
It's very scary.
这太可怕了。
--but didn't make Daniel stop.
——但并没有阻止Daniel。
I just climbed everything I could find.
我只是爬遍了我能找到的一切。
And when the elementary school called and asked her to make Daniel stop clicking--
当小学打电话叫她让Daniel停止点击时——
It's not socially acceptable, is what they would say.
他们会说，这在社交上是不可接受的。
--Paulette said, too bad.
——Paulette说，那太遗憾了。
He needs to know what's around him, and that's how he does it.
他需要知道周围有什么，而这就是他做到的方式。
And so Daniel clicked, [TONGUE CLICKING], past people doing double takes on the street, [TONGUE CLICKING], occasionally bumping into things.
于是Daniel点击着，[舌头点击声]，经过街上那些回头看他的人，[舌头点击声]，偶尔撞到东西。
(CHUCKLING) Yep.
（轻笑）没错。
And then pretty soon--
然后很快——
Your blind kid is not only scaling trees and fences by himself, but using just his clicks-- not even using a cane at that point-- he's walking to school by himself, crossing busy roads, exploring his way into neighbors' driveways.
你的盲孩子不仅自己爬树翻墙，而且仅靠点击——那时甚至不用手杖——他就能自己走路去上学，穿过繁忙的道路，探索着走进邻居的车道。
A friend of the family had an undersized bike, and I started riding alongside this retainer wall, until I realized I didn't really need the wall and I could roll alongside the wall without having to touch the wall. And then--
我们家有个朋友有一辆尺寸偏小的自行车，我开始沿着这堵挡土墙骑，直到我意识到我并不真的需要这堵墙，我可以沿着墙边骑而不需要触碰它。然后——
Oh, goodness.
哦，天哪。
I just could ride it.
我就能骑了。
He'd have to click way more than usual.
他不得不比平时点击得更多。
Peppering the environment with a barrage of clicks. [TONGUE CLICKING]
用大量的点击充斥环境。[舌头点击声]
But by six years old, he could do it-- ride completely comfortably on the bike.
但到了六岁，他就能做到了——非常舒适地骑自行车。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
And when neighbors would pop their heads out the door--
当邻居们探出头来——
How can you let him do that?
你怎么能让他那样做？
--with their concerns--
——带着他们的担忧——
How can you let him do that? How can you let him do that? How can you let him do that?
你怎么能让他那样做？你怎么能让他那样做？你怎么能让他那样做？
--she'd look at his smiling face--
——她看着他微笑的脸庞——
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
--and think--
——心想——
How can I not?
我怎么能不让他做呢？
Hey, Lulu?
嘿，Lulu？
Yeah, Alix?
在，Alix？
Can I cut in with a question?
我能插个问题吗？
Yeah.
可以。
Did he ever get hurt? Like, really hurt?
他有没有受过伤？那种，真的受伤？
Well--
嗯——
I used to have this game, get to the top of our road and yell, dive bomb, and I would ride insanely fast down the road. And everyone would have to scatter. Well, one day, I did the dive bomb thing, and as I was screaming down this road, bang. I just collided into a metal light pole.
我过去有个游戏，跑到我们这条路的尽头大喊“俯冲轰炸”，然后我会以极快的速度骑车冲下坡。每个人都得散开。嗯，有一天，我做了那个俯冲轰炸，当我尖叫着冲下这条路时，砰。我直接撞上了一个金属灯柱。
Oy.
噢。
Blood everywhere.
到处都是血。
And this was not the only pole in Daniel's life. On the schoolyard, he ran into a pole and knocked out his front teeth.
而且这并不是Daniel生命中唯一的柱子。在校园里，他撞上了一根柱子，磕掉了门牙。
Teeth.
牙齿。
A few years after that, he ran straight into a soccer shed.
几年后，他又直接撞进了足球棚。
And it just destroyed my whole mouth.
把我的整张嘴都毁了。
So yeah, he got injured pretty badly a bunch of times. But the way that Paulette reacted to these injuries--
所以是的，他受过好几次重伤。但Paulette对这些伤势的反应——
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
--was that she always let him keep going. I mean, shortly after the bike thing, a bicycle appeared under the Christmas tree.
——是她总是让他继续前进。我的意思是，在骑自行车的事情发生后不久，圣诞树下就出现了一辆自行车。
And, like, I am a mother, and I think that if my kid kept showing up with his front teeth knocked out, I would begin to wonder if I had made the right choice.
而且，作为一名母亲，我想如果我的孩子一直因为磕掉门牙而回来，我会开始怀疑我是否做出了正确的选择。
Yeah. Paulette knows it seems extreme, which brings me to the reason she decided to do this, to raise her blind kid so differently from the way that most blind kids are raised.
是的。Paulette知道这看起来很极端，这引出了她决定这样做的原因，把她的盲孩子抚养得与大多数盲童的养育方式如此不同。
It was my first marriage. It was not a good marriage.
那是我的第一次婚姻。那不是一段好婚姻。
My father was an alcoholic, and he was abusive.
我父亲是个酒鬼，他很有暴力倾向。
Daniel's biological father, who's now dead, would hit Paulette.
Daniel的亲生父亲，现在已经去世了，会打Paulette。
Sort of a barroom brawler type.
算是一种酒吧斗殴型的人。
And he was tough with Daniel and Daniel's little brother, taught them to fight.
他对Daniel和Daniel的弟弟很强硬，教他们打架。
And we had to learn to sort of take physical punishment, as it were, and be able to dish it back.
我们必须学会忍受肉体上的惩罚，并学会还手。
And Paulette says this is why she ended up being so hands-off with Daniel.
Paulette说这就是为什么她最终对Daniel如此放手。
[SIGH] Everything that happens in your life has its effect, has its effect.
[叹气] 你生命中发生的每一件事都有其影响，有其影响。
She says that after years of feeling so small and powerless in that marriage, when she finally made it out, she vowed never to be ruled by fear again.
她说在经历了那段婚姻中感到如此渺小和无力之后，当她最终逃出来时，她发誓再也不被恐惧所支配。
I mean, there's life, and then there is living your life. There is a difference.
我的意思是，生活是一回事，活出你的生活是另一回事。这两者是有区别的。
And the same would go for Daniel. She refused to let those scary thoughts of what could happen make her keep Daniel too close.
对Daniel来说也是如此。她拒绝让那些关于可能发生什么的恐怖想法使她把Daniel管得太紧。
But what if Daniel ended up being hit by a car and killed?
但如果Daniel最终被车撞死呢？
I asked her.
我问过她。
Like, what if-- what if a car just hits and just plows him down?
比如，如果——如果一辆车直接撞过去把他碾压了呢？
But that could happen to anyone. That could happen to anyone. There was a group of four kids on the corner up about a block, a car went up the curb and hit them, killed two of them. It could happen to anyone.
但这可能发生在任何人身上。这可能发生在任何人身上。街角那边曾有一群四个孩子，一辆车冲上路缘撞倒了他们，撞死了两个。这可能发生在任何人身上。
And so bikes were bought for Christmas.
所以圣诞节买了自行车。
Yeah.
是的。
And tree climbing was permitted.
允许爬树。
OK. I'll just close my eyes.
好的，我闭上眼睛。
And this blind little boy was allowed to wander the world as freely as any sighted child.
而这个失明的小男孩被允许像任何视力正常的孩子一样自由地游荡在世界上。
From the fifth grade on, I walked to school almost every day. I had to cross major streets. I participated in extracurricular activities. I made my own breakfast. I made my own lunch.
从五年级开始，我几乎每天都走路去上学。我必须穿过主要的街道。我参加课外活动。我自己做早餐。我自己做午餐。
I mean, were they considered outside the norm? Did they consider themselves outside the norm?
我的意思是，他们被视为异类吗？他们把自己视为异类吗？
I don't think they noticed it much. I don't think they thought about it much. Particularly Daniel didn't know that there was anything odd about the way he got around the world.
我不认为他们太在意这些。我不认为他们想过这些。特别是Daniel不知道他四处走动的方式有什么奇怪的。
Until Adam.
直到Adam出现。
My name is Adam Shaible. Excuse me for a second.
我叫Adam Shaible。请稍等一下。
So Alix?
所以Alix？
Yeah.
在。
This is where the story takes a kind of complicated turn, because Adam is basically the first other blind person that Daniel ever encounters. They meet in the fifth grade, when Adam suddenly enrolls in Daniel's school.
这就是故事变得有点复杂的地方，因为Adam基本上是Daniel遇到的第一个盲人。他们在五年级时相遇，当时Adam突然转入Daniel的学校。
I will say, I was a rather small fellow at the time. When I was 11, 12, I was under 60 pounds.
我得说，当时我是个相当小的家伙。11、12岁时，我还不到60磅。
Wow.
哇。
And Daniel was not exactly welcoming.
而Daniel并不是很友好。
He just wasn't a nice-- a nice fellow.
他只是不是一个好——不是一个好家伙。
Daniel said that Adam completely unnerved him because of how incapable he was of getting around on his own.
Daniel说Adam完全让他不安，因为他太无能了，根本无法独自四处走动。
Literally just running into walls. I mean, he would just walk along, and his forehead would connect with a wall. And we'd be on the other side of that wall, and we would say, OK, that's Adam, he's coming, kind of thing.
简直就是直接撞墙。我的意思是，他会走着走着，前额就撞上墙壁。我们会在墙的那边，我们会说，噢，那是Adam，他来了，类似那样。
Is that true? Was it, like, that bad?
那是真的吗？真的有那么严重吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Adam says he had simply never needed to get around on his own before.
Adam说他之前根本不需要独自四处走动。
I went to the School for the Blind from age five to age seven.
我五岁到七岁都在盲校上学。
And there, he was taken around on someone's arm almost all the time. In the lunchroom, people brought him his food. They helped him carry his books, helped him tie his shoelaces.
在那里，他几乎一直被人挽着走。在午餐室里，人们给他送食物。他们帮他拿书，帮他系鞋带。
I don't know why people did things for me. They just did.
我不知道为什么人们为我做这些。他们就是做了。
And Daniel was baffled by Adam.
而Daniel被Adam搞糊涂了。
At the time, I had not really conceptualized blindness in that way for myself. And I just didn't understand it.
当时，我还没有真正为自己把失明定义成那样。而且我只是不理解。
He'd come home to his mom mystified.
他会困惑地回到家找他妈妈。
He'd say, Adam can't do anything on his own.
他会说，Adam什么事都不能自己做。
If I got lost, I used to get terrified.
如果我迷路了，我过去会被吓坏的。
Why?
为什么？
I just-- I didn't feel safe.
我只是——我觉得不安全。
Why?
为什么？
And then what happened is that the kids at school started to mix up Daniel and Adam.
然后发生的事情是，学校里的孩子们开始混淆Daniel和Adam。
People started just lumping us together as the blind kids. We were the same age.
人们开始直接把我们统称为“盲孩子”。我们年纪一样。
You were the blind boys.
你们是盲人男孩。
Yeah. They'd mix up our names, and I didn't like that at all.
是的。他们会混淆我们的名字，我一点也不喜欢这样。
And so almost to prove his distinction from Adam--
所以为了证明他与Adam的区别——
I did the things that kids will do in situations like that.
我做了孩子们在这种情况下会做的事。
What did you do?
你做了什么？
Um--
嗯——
He made fun of Adam.
他取笑Adam。
He started bullying him.
他开始霸凌他。
I wondered if there was something I had done.
我纳闷是否我做过什么。
He'd tease him in front of other kids--
他在其他孩子面前戏弄他——
I was pretty brutal.
我相当残忍。
--and even beat him up a few times.
——甚至打过他几次。
Yeah.
是的。
And that, in my aggressive little mind, was the thing that set me apart.
而那，在我那好斗的小脑瓜里，就是让我与众不同的事情。
I wanted to be his friend.
我本想成为他的朋友。
So then what happened?
那后来呢？
Um--
嗯——
Time moved on.
时光流逝。
Adam and Daniel went to different schools, and Daniel just tried his best to forget this kid so like him, who couldn't get around in the world.
Adam和Daniel去了不同的学校，Daniel只是尽力忘记这个和他如此相似、却无法在这个世界上独立行走的孩子。
And um, we just lost track--
而嗯，我们就失去了联系——
We just lost track of each other.
我们只是失去了彼此的联系。
Daniel goes off to college, doesn't really associate himself with the blind community. His plan is to become a researcher, an autism researcher. And then one day, he happens to pick up this book.
Daniel上大学去了，并不太认同自己属于盲人社区。他的计划是成为一名研究员，一名自闭症研究员。然后有一天，他偶然拿起这本书。
The title is The Making of Blind Men .
书名是《盲人的制造》（The Making of Blind Men）。
The Making of Blind Men by Robert Scott.
Robert Scott写的《盲人的制造》。
I go by Bob. You can spell that either way.
我叫Bob。你怎么拼都行。
All right.
好的。
This is the book's author, Bob Scott, a former professor of sociology at Princeton. And inside this book was the idea that would change Daniel's life, an idea that when you first hear it sounds kind of out there-- that blindness is a social construction.
这是作者Bob Scott，普林斯顿大学的一位前社会学教授。书里有一个想法彻底改变了Daniel的一生，一个你第一次听到会觉得有点古怪的想法——失明是一种社会建构。
Wait, was Bob saying that people are not physically blind?
等等，Bob是说人们并没有生理上的失明吗？
Kind of. But let me just tell you how he gets there.
算是吧。但让我告诉你他是怎么得出这个结论的。
OK.
好的。
OK?
好的？
OK.
好的。
So fresh out of grad school, Bob got this job to conduct a huge, multi-year long survey to see how effective blindness organizations were at helping the blind.
刚从研究生院毕业，Bob得到了一份工作，要进行一项大型的、为期多年的调查，看看盲人组织在帮助盲人方面有多有效。
Yep.
没错。
And so he begins interviewing hundreds of blind people, goes out on hundreds of site visits.
于是他开始采访数百名盲人，进行了数百次实地考察。
Basically gathering information in any way I could imagine that I could get it.
基本上以我能想到的任何方式收集信息。
And then one day, many months into the process, he had--
然后有一天，在流程进行了几个月后，他有了——
What might be called an aha moment.
可能被称为“顿悟时刻”的东西。
He was out walking in a snowstorm in New York City, when he happened to see--
他当时正走在纽约市的一场暴风雪中，偶然看到——
A blind beggar--
一个盲乞丐——
--asking for money--
——正在要钱——
--standing on the corner at Bloomingdale's.
——站在Bloomingdale百货大楼的拐角处。
And he thought, hey, someone else to interview for my survey.
他心想，嘿，正好可以采访另一个人加入我的调查。
I said, would you allow me to buy some of your time? And I gave him-- I don't know-- $25 or something like that. We went in and sat down at a restaurant, and I said, tell me your story.
我说，你愿意让我买你的一些时间吗？我给了他——我不记得了——25美元左右。我们进去坐在餐馆里，我说，告诉我你的故事。
Turns out the man had worked at a paint factory until a few years before, when an accident there left him blind. And the people at the factory really liked the guy, so they said, look, why don't you go to an organization for the blind, get some training, and then come back and work for us? So the guy said, great.
事实证明，那个人几年前一直在油漆厂工作，直到一次事故让他失明。工厂里的人非常喜欢他，所以他们说，看，你为什么不去盲人组织，接受培训，然后再回来为我们工作？那个人说，太棒了。
He went to an organization for the blind. He said, I've got this job all lined up. Can you just help me with a few basic things. And the blindness organization said no.
他去了盲人组织。他说，我已经安排好了工作。能不能帮我处理一些基本的事情。盲人组织说不。
Oh, no. You can't do that. Blind people can't do those things. What we're going to do is put you through a program of rehabilitation and then move you along to our sheltered workshop that manufactures mops and brooms.
噢，不行。你不能那样做。盲人不能做那些事。我们要把你送进一个康复计划，然后把你安排到我们生产拖把和扫帚的庇护工场。
And Bob said there was one sentence in that response that jumped out at him.
Bob说，回应中有一句话让他印象深刻。
Blind people can't do those things.
盲人不能做那些事。
And he began to wonder, wait, is that true? Could this guy really not work in a paint factory? Because over the course of his research, he'd seen blind people that could do all sorts of things. And the more that Bob looked around, he started to see that message--
他开始怀疑，等等，那是真的吗？那个人真的不能在油漆厂工作吗？因为在他的研究过程中，他见过盲人能做各种各样的事情。Bob看得越多，他开始看到那种信息——
Blind people can't do those things.
盲人不能做那些事。
--being communicated to the blind people by the blind organizations that serve them-- not necessarily always as explicitly as in the case of the paint guy.
——被盲人组织传达给盲人——在油漆工那个案例中未必总是那么明确。
Like, how else then?
比如，那除此之外呢？
Well, take the fact that at that time, of the almost 20,000 blind kids that were in America, 2/3 of them were being kept on the sidelines in gym class. Play tag, run around on your own--
嗯，看看当时的情况，在美国近20,000名盲童中，有2/3在体育课上被晾在一边。玩抓人游戏，自己四处跑——
Blind people can't do those things.
盲人不能做那些事。
And then there was the organization's insistence that adult blind people get help getting around.
还有就是组织坚持让成年盲人在四处走动时获得帮助。
They are picked up at their homes. They're driven there. They're met at the sidewalk, walked into the agency, escorted to wherever they're going-- everything is being done for them.
他们在家门口被接走。他们被开车带到那里。他们在人行道上被接住，带进机构，护送到他们要去的地方——所有事情都在为他们代劳。
And even though all this was intended to help, Bob began to wonder if maybe, just maybe, the organizations' low expectations for what blind people could do was in some way actually limiting the blind people that those organizations sought to help.
尽管所有这些都是为了帮忙，Bob开始怀疑，也许，仅仅也许，组织对盲人能做什么的低期望，在某种程度上实际上限制了那些寻求帮助的盲人。
What I came to realize is that how they functioned was a process of learning. It was not imposed on them entirely by the fact that they couldn't see.
我最终意识到的是，他们的功能运作是一个学习过程。它并非完全由他们看不见这一事实强加给他们的。
Hey, Lulu?
嘿，Lulu？
Yeah, Alix?
在，Alix？
So is Bob saying that blindness is mostly in our head? That blind people can actually do everything that sighted people can do? Because my dad is blind, and he is very, very limited in what he can do. And I gotta say, I don't feel like the obstacles that he faces are obstacles that he wouldn't face if he just thought differently about his blindness.
所以Bob是说失明主要是我们脑子里的问题？盲人实际上能做视力正常人能做的一切吗？因为我爸爸是盲人，他在能做的事情上非常、非常受限。我得说，我不觉得他面临的障碍是如果他改变对失明的想法就能克服的。
Well, Bob is pretty hardcore about this. I think he would say that with enough time, your dad actually could do a lot more, because he thinks the only real absolute physical limitation of blindness is about an inability to perceive things in the distance.
嗯，Bob在这方面态度相当强硬。我想他会说，只要有足够的时间，你爸爸实际上可以做得更多，因为他认为失明唯一真正绝对的生理局限在于无法感知远处的事物。
Exactly, anything that I can't reach out and touch.
没错，任何我伸出手够不到的东西。
But you can compensate for everything else. And Alix?
但你可以补偿其他一切。而且Alix？
Uh-huh?
嗯哼？
Bob wasn't actually the first person to come up with this idea. Blind people were. A group called the National Federation of the Blind has for a long time advocated this kind of idea. This is a group formed by blind people for blind people, and they think that the physical condition of blindness--
Bob实际上并不是第一个想到这个想法的人。盲人自己就是。一个叫全国盲人联合会的组织长期以来一直提倡这种想法。这是一个由盲人为了盲人组成的组织，他们认为失明的生理状况——
It doesn't explain nearly as much as people believe it explains.
它解释的东西远没有人们相信的那么多。
So if you buy this logic, people who are blind-- like, the only thing that's standing between them and walking around the world, like Daniel does, is our beliefs?
所以如果你相信这个逻辑，盲人——比如，阻挡他们和像Daniel那样在世界上行走之间唯一的障碍，就是我们的信仰？
Yeah. You know, that sounds totally crazy, and that is exactly what he's saying. Which brings us back to Daniel. Daniel reads this book, and he starts thinking about Adam.
是的。你知道，那听起来完全疯狂，而这正是他在说的。这就把我们带回了Daniel。Daniel读了这本书，他开始想起Adam。
If I got lost, I used to get terrified.
如果我迷路了，我过去会被吓坏的。
You know, maybe it wasn't that Adam was this weirdo, tentative kid but that he was a very typical product of a system.
你知道，也许并不是Adam是个奇怪、胆小的孩子，而是他是一个体制下的典型产物。
You mean, like, the system taught Adam that he would have trouble moving around.
你是说，就像体制教会了Adam在四处走动时会遇到困难。
Yeah. I mean, he was led around school. People brought him his food--
是的。我的意思是，他在学校里被人领着走。人们给他送食物——
I don't know why people did things for me. They just did.
我不知道为什么人们为我做这些。他们就是做了。
And when Daniel looked at the world around him, he thought, you know, a lot has changed. But a lot is frighteningly similar.
当Daniel审视他周围的世界时，他心想，你知道，很多事情都改变了。但很多事情依然令人害怕地相似。
From then till today, things are similar?
从那时到现在，情况依然相似？
Yeah.
是的。
I called around to over a dozen blindness organizations all over the country.
我给全国各地的十几家盲人组织打了电话。
My name is Daniel Norris, supervisor of adult services for the Vermont Association for the Blind and Visually Impaired.
我叫Daniel Norris，佛蒙特州盲人和视障人士协会的成人服务主管。
And supervisor after supervisor told me that what Bob Scott saw is still very much alive today.
主管一个接一个地告诉我，Bob Scott看到的现象今天依然非常活跃。
In what way?
在什么方面？
So most children who are blind in America don't actually go to schools for the blind anymore.
所以，在美国，大多数盲童实际上不再去盲校了。
Right.
对。
Thanks to the Education for All Handicapped Children Act of 1975, most blind kids stay in their local public schools, which is great. But on those public school grounds, says Norris--
感谢1975年的《所有残疾儿童教育法》，大多数盲童留在当地的公立学校，这很好。但据Norris说，在那些公立学校里——
There is a lot of pressure to keep a child safe, especially in a litigious society.
有很大的压力要保持孩子的安全，尤其是在一个好诉讼的社会里。
So many of the blind students are still placed with a paraeducator, which can be good. But sometimes--
所以许多盲生仍然被安排了一位辅助教师，这可能是件好事。但有时——
Those paraeducators can end up doing the work for the kids.
那些辅助教师最终会替孩子们做功课。
Like Adam.
像Adam那样。
When you lighten someone's load, you don't allow them to expand.
当你减轻一个人的负担时，你就不允许他们成长。
I talked to mothers whose blind kids were pulled off of playground equipment. And perhaps the most chilling thing is the fact that most blind kids will intuitively start clicking--
我采访了一些母亲，她们的盲孩子被从游乐设备上拉下来。也许最令人不寒而栗的是，大多数盲童会直觉地开始点击——
[TONGUE CLICKING]
[舌头点击声]
--or snapping or stamping to test out their environment with sound. But they are so often discouraged--
——或者拍打、跺脚来用声音测试环境。但他们经常被劝阻——
It's not socially acceptable, is what they would say.
他们会说，这在社交上是不可接受的。
--that they never get the chance to develop their skill to the level Daniel did.
——以至于他们从没机会把自己的技能发展到Daniel那样的水平。
So how are we doing as a nation? We have not taught independence.
那么作为国家，我们做得如何？我们没有教授独立。
He points out that in America, a majority of blind people are unemployed. And while that could be for a lot of reasons, Norris thinks that's on us.
他指出，在美国，大多数盲人是失业的。虽然这可能有很多原因，但Norris认为这是我们的责任。
What we are doing is we are creating slaves to others' thinking.
我们在做的，是创造他人思想的奴隶。
That's Daniel Kish again.
那是Daniel Kish。
Slaves to others' perception, slaves to what others think they should be doing. And somehow we're comfortable with that.
他人感知的奴隶，他人认为他们应该做什么的奴隶。而不知何故，我们对此感到心安理得。
And so, though he had never wanted to work in the profession of blindness-- in fact, he'd wanted to get as far away from it as he could-- Daniel Kish decided he sort of had no choice.
所以，虽然他从未想过从事失明相关的工作——事实上，他曾想尽可能远离它——Daniel Kish还是决定他没得选。
It sucked me in kind of kicking and screaming.
它是踢打着、尖叫着把我吸进去的。
He could see what was happening. And he held in his tongue, [TONGUE CLICKING], a way out. So he decided that he would dedicate his life to trying to liberate blind children.
他能看到正在发生什么。而他握着他的舌头，[舌头点击声]，一条出路。所以他决定献身于尝试解放盲童。
Kind of like Batman?
有点像蝙蝠侠？
Exactamundo, fighting for good in the world in a kind of vigilante way, because actually, the way that you go about liberating a blind child from the constraining forces of culture, it can get kind of ugly.
完全正确，以一种义务警员的方式在世界上为善而战，因为实际上，你试图将盲童从文化的约束力中解放出来的方式，可能会变得有点丑陋。
Coming up, the Dark Knight rises. Lulu and Alix are back in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
稍后，黑暗骑士崛起。Lulu和Alix将在片刻后回来，节目将继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we have a story from a brand new radio show and podcast called Invisibilia . It's from NPR News. Science reporters Alix Spiegel and Lulu Miller are the hosts. And they're here today talking about how profoundly other people's expectations can affect us and about a blind man named Daniel Kish. Anyway, again, here's Alix.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天在我们的节目中，有一个来自一档全新的广播节目和播客《无形》（Invisibilia）的故事。它来自NPR新闻。科学记者Alix Spiegel和Lulu Miller是主持人。她们今天在这里谈论他人的期望是如何深远地影响我们的，以及关于一位名叫Daniel Kish的盲人。总之，再次有请Alix。
So when last we met Daniel, he had decided that he was going to become a kind of real-life Batman who would save people who were blind from the low expectations of their culture. But before we keep going, I should probably point out that lots of blind people don't necessarily want him as their savior. A bunch of them told us, basically, clicks shmicks!
上次我们见到Daniel时，他已决定成为一个现实生活中的“蝙蝠侠”，拯救那些盲人，使他们免受文化中低期望的影响。但在继续之前，我应该指出，很多盲人并不一定想要他作为救世主。他们中有一群人告诉我们，基本上，点击什么的，胡扯！
Because I get along just fine without doing that clicking noise, or whatever he calls it.
因为我不做那个点击声或他叫的那什么玩意，也过得挺好。
This is Bob Ringwald, a musician in California. He says he's got a cane. It works great. He does everything he wants.
这是加州的音乐家Bob Ringwald。他说他有一根手杖。用起来很棒。他做他想做的一切。
When I wanted to learn guitar, I did, and I've done a lot of climbing around on my roof and climbing up poles. And anything I wanted to do, I did.
当我想学吉他时，我就学了，我还在屋顶上爬过，爬过杆子。任何我想做的事，我都做了。
Now, Bob Ringwald-- in fact, all of the blind people that we spoke to for this story-- agreed with Daniel that low expectations hold blind people back. But that didn't necessarily mean that they wanted to echolocate. For example, when Bob Ringwald was seven, in school for the blind back in the '50s, he knew some kids who clicked and said they just seemed a little weird.
现在，Bob Ringwald——事实上，我们为这个故事采访的所有盲人都同意Daniel的看法，即低期望束缚了盲人。但这并不一定意味着他们想要回声定位。例如，当Bob Ringwald七岁、在50年代的盲校时，他认识一些会点击的孩子，说他们看起来只是有点怪。
I really didn't want to go through life clicking all the time. A lot of people think blind people are strange. So I didn't want to be any stranger than I already was.
我真的不想一辈子点击个不停。很多人认为盲人很奇怪。所以我不想比已经这样更奇怪了。
A lot of instructors don't like people to do that, because it does look funny.
很多老师不喜欢人们这样做，因为它看起来很有趣。
Eric Woods is also blind, and a retired mobility instructor in Colorado.
Eric Woods也是盲人，是科罗拉多州退休的移动指导员。
And it's socially unacceptable-- not unacceptable, but it's socially different. And so it has been discouraged. I've heard plenty of people discourage it.
这在社交上是不可接受的——不是不可接受，但它在社交上与众不同。所以它受到了劝阻。我听说过很多人劝阻它。
And Daniel knew this. He knew what he was up against. So Lulu, what did Daniel do?
Daniel也知道这一点。他知道自己面临的是什么。那么Lulu，Daniel做了什么？
Well, he starts up a nonprofit, as you do-- a nonprofit that will teach people how to echolocate.
嗯，他创办了一个非营利组织，像你做的那样——一个将教授人们如何回声定位的非营利组织。
Grace.
恩典。
This is one of his early instructional videos. It's now 2001, and since his aim is nothing short of liberation, he calls it World Access for the Blind.
这是他早期的教学视频之一。现在是2001年，由于他的目标无异于解放，他称之为“盲人世界通道”（World Access for the Blind）。
World Access for the Blind.
盲人世界通道。
Now, the only little problem that he runs into is that at that time, a blind person teaching another blind person how to get around is basically unheard of.
现在，他遇到的唯一一个小问题是，当时，一个盲人教另一个盲人如何四处走动基本上是闻所未闻的。
The blind cannot lead the blind is right out of the Bible. It's fundamental to our culture.
“盲人不能引领盲人”直接出自《圣经》。这是我们文化的根本。
In fact, until the mid '90s--
事实上，直到90年代中期——
There was no certification for blind people to train other blind people.
盲人培训其他盲人是没有认证的。
Wow.
哇。
Blind people can't do those things.
盲人不能做那些事。
So this is actually when the bike trick became big-- like, though he sort of hates "Look at the blind man ride a bike," he realized that could get him attention. So he starts going on all these TV shows with his trick.
所以这实际上就是那个自行车技巧变得有名的时候——虽然他有点讨厌“看盲人骑车”，但他意识到那能为他带来关注。所以他开始带着他的技巧去参加所有这些电视节目。
And my segment was between something about vampires and some other thing about faith healing or whatever.
而我的环节是在关于吸血鬼和另一个关于信仰疗法或类似的事情之间。
And on these TV appearances, he'd try to send some sort of signal to blind kids who might be watching, who might be able to contact him.
在这些电视节目中，他会尝试向可能正在观看、可能能够联系到他的盲童发送某种信号。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Dan, can anyone learn this?
Dan，任何人都能学吗？
Echolocation is a skill-- piano playing, for example. Some people may be more talented than others, but I think that anyone could learn it.
回声定位是一种技能——比如弹钢琴。有些人可能比其他人更有天赋，但我认为任何人都能学会。
And it worked.
而且它奏效了。
Yeah.
是的。
Slowly but surely, families started contacting him, which meant that Daniel was now faced with a question. Could he actually undo the damage of low expectations? And this is where things begin to get a little morally complicated.
慢慢地，确定地，家庭开始联系他，这意味着Daniel现在面临一个问题。他真的能撤销低期望带来的伤害吗？这就是事情开始变得有点道德复杂的地方。
The example I'm about to give is an example that took place about 10 years ago.
我接下来要给的例子是大约10年前发生的例子。
Daniel told me about going out to teach one of his first students ever, a little 10-year-old boy.
Daniel告诉了我他去教他最早的学生之一、一个10岁小男孩的情况。
He lives on an apple orchard--
他住在一个苹果园里——
Out in Washington state.
在华盛顿州。
I come out. And basically, what I see is a boy who won't leave his house.
我出来。基本上，我看到的是一个不愿离开房子的男孩。
And so Daniel's idea was to get him to climb a tree.
所以Daniel的想法是让他去爬树。
They live on an orchard full of trees, for goodness' sakes.
天哪，他们住在一个到处都是树的果园里。
But the kid won't budge. So to get him out the door, Daniel takes away all his toys.
但孩子不肯挪窝。所以为了让他出门，Daniel拿走了他所有的玩具。
Our purpose was to kind of simulate the world that he was choosing for himself. So this is what life will have in store for you-- basically nothing, OK? Nothing.
我们的目的是为了模拟他为自己选择的世界。所以这就是生活为你准备的东西——基本上什么都没有，好吗？什么都没有。
And after about a week, the kid finally agrees to go climb a frickin' tree. And he gets up onto the first branch and the second branch and then says, OK.
在大约一周后，孩子终于同意去爬一棵该死的树。他爬上了第一根树枝，第二根树枝，然后说，好吧。
I give up. I give up. Yeah, but you know what? Giving up isn't an option. You can decide never to climb a tree for the rest of your life, but we are going to climb this one. And I said, you can go up, you cannot go down. And he just had a fit-- literally screaming himself hoarse. I mean, he actually jumped at one point. Like, he actually leapt off the tree, he was in such a frenzy.
我放弃了。我放弃了。好吧，但你知道吗？放弃不是一个选择。你可以决定余生再也不爬树，但我们今天要爬这一棵。我说，你可以上去，你不可以下来。他只是发脾气——字面上把自己吼到嘶哑。我的意思是，他甚至在某个时候跳了。他真的从树上跳了下来，因为他太狂躁了。
Oh my god, Lulu. And what does Daniel do?
噢天哪，Lulu。Daniel做了什么？
Well, he catches him. He's right below him. And he just says, no.
嗯，他接住了他。他在他下面。他只是说，不。
You can go up. You cannot go down.
你可以上去。你不可以下来。
And they stay in this tree battling it out.
他们待在树上较劲。
Inch by inch by-- it took three hours to get up a 60-foot tree.
一寸一寸地——爬上那棵60英尺高的树花了我三个小时。
But by the end, the kid was doing it himself.
但最后，孩子自己做到了。
--doing it himself. He started finding his own footholds, finding his own handholds.
——自己做到了。他开始寻找自己的落脚点，寻找自己的手抓点。
And Daniel thinks this training and how the parents then took it on too changed the boy's life.
Daniel认为这种训练，以及父母后来也采取了这种方式，改变了男孩的生活。
By the age of 13, he was out of his shell. He had joined Boy Scouts. That is in no way where he was headed.
到13岁时，他走出了外壳。他参加了童子军。那绝对不是他原先的方向。
Hm. That is just crazy, though, that story, on some level. I don't know if that kind of bullying is even allowed in America anymore, you know?
嗯。这真是太疯狂了，在某种程度上。我不知道在美国这种霸凌是否还被允许，你知道吗？
Yeah. And most schools for the blind have been reluctant to hire him because of liability issues. They're scared it'll be too dangerous for their students.
是的。大多数盲校都因为责任问题而不愿雇佣他。他们担心这对学生来说太危险。
I bet.
我敢肯定。
But see, Daniel would say that attitude, Alix, is part of the problem. So what are a few tears, huh, a few scratches? He has this line he always says.
但你看，Daniel会说那种态度，Alix，是问题的一部分。所以一点眼泪算什么，几个划痕又算什么？他总有这一句话。
Running into a pole is a drag. But never being allowed to run into a pole is a disaster.
撞上柱子是件扫兴的事。但从不被允许撞上柱子却是一场灾难。
He worries that when you prevent a kid from, say, running into a pole, what you end up preventing them from is the kind of experience that allow for-- and this gets me back to that crazy sounding claim he made at the beginning of the show-- actual sight.
他担心当你阻止一个孩子撞上柱子时，你最终阻止他们的是那种允许——这就让我回到了他在节目开头提出的那个听起来很疯狂的声明——真正的视力。
If our culture recognized the capacity of blind people to see, then more blind people would learn to see. It's actually pretty simple and straightforward.
如果我们的文化认可盲人看见的能力，那么更多的盲人就会学会看见。这实际上非常简单直接。
Daniel thinks this because, well, he says he sees.
Daniel这么认为是因为，嗯，他说他看见了。
I definitely would say that I experience images, that I have images.
我绝对会说我体验到图像，我有图像。
And he isn't talking metaphorically here.
而且他在这里不是在隐喻。
They are images of spatial character and depth that have a lot of the same qualities that a person who sees would see.
它们是具有空间特征和深度的图像，具有很多视力正常人能看到的内容的相同品质。
Hello?
喂？
Hi.
嗨。
This is Lore Thaler, a German neuroscientist at Durham University in the UK. And Lore knows a lot about sight. She studies vision in the brain-- literally how the images we see are constructed.
这是Lore Thaler，英国杜伦大学的德国神经科学家。Lore对视觉了解很多。她研究大脑中的视觉——字面上讲，我们看到的图像是如何构建的。
It sounds simple, but an image is actually a complex construct.
这听起来很简单，但图像实际上是一个复杂的构建。
Several years ago, Lore happened across a video of Daniel.
几年前，Lore偶然看到了Daniel的视频。
OK, so we had a little string of parked vehicles there--
好的，所以我们那里有一串停放的车辆——
And as she watched the way that he so easily moved through space, she found herself wondering, was there any way that Daniel's brain was indeed constructing images?
当她看着他如此轻松地在空间中移动的方式时，她发现自己在想，Daniel的大脑是否确实在构建图像？
It was so akin to vision, really.
这确实非常类似于视觉。
OK, so you may know this already, but Lore reminded me that an image, even though it feels like it's out there in the world in front of your eyes actually exists behind the eyes.
好的，所以你可能已经知道了，但Lore提醒我，图像，尽管感觉像是存在于你眼前世界中，实际上存在于眼睛之后。
The image, it's something that your mind constructs.
图像，那是你的大脑构建的东西。
In a part of your brain called the visual cortex. So Lore brought Daniel and a few other people who can echolocate into her lab, and she took recordings of them while they clicked at different objects in space.
在大脑中一个叫视觉皮层的部位。所以Lore把Daniel和另外几位能回声定位的人带进了她的实验室，她给他们在点击空间中不同物体时做了记录。
[TONGUE CLICKING]
[舌头点击声]
A car, a lamppost-- these are her actual recordings-- a salad bowl, a salad bowl in motion.
汽车、灯柱——这些是她实际的录音——沙拉碗，运动中的沙拉碗。
How do you get a salad bowl in motion?
你是怎么得到运动中的沙拉碗的？
You stand behind the person with a salad bowl on a fishing pole, and you slowly wave it.
你站在那个人身后，用鱼竿挑着沙拉碗，然后慢慢地挥舞。
Right.
对。
And the microphones were actually in their ears.
麦克风实际上在他们的耳朵里。
So we recorded what they heard exactly.
所以我们记录了他们听到的确切内容。
Oh, that's neat.
哦，那太棒了。
And then she played the recordings back to them, one object at a time, while they were lying down in fMRI machines, so she could watch how their brains responded. [TONGUE CLICKING] Salad bowl. [TONGUE CLICKING] Salad bowl in motion.
然后她把录音回放给他们，一次一个物体，同时他们躺在fMRI机器里，这样她就可以观察他们的大脑是如何反应的。[舌头点击声] 沙拉碗。[舌头点击声] 运动中的沙拉碗。
And then in a second study, she compared those readings to what happens in the brains of sighted people looking at the same kinds of things. Salad bowl. Salad bowl in motion.
然后在第二次研究中，她将这些读数与视力正常人看同样东西时大脑发生的情况进行了比较。沙拉碗。运动中的沙拉碗。
Very clever, very clever.
非常聪明，非常聪明。
Yep. And what she found is that even though for decades scientists assumed that the visual cortex goes dark when you are blind, Daniel's was lighting up like a disco ball.
没错。她发现，尽管几十年来科学家们认为当你失明时视觉皮层会变暗，但Daniel的视觉皮层像迪斯科球一样闪亮。
Yeah, so that was really very impressive.
是的，所以那确实非常令人印象深刻。
And the way in which it was lighting up-- this is really cool. So it turns out that there are all these different parts of the brain involved in vision. So there's an area that's specifically dedicated to processing motion, and that's way over here behind the ears. And then there's a completely different area for texture--
它闪亮的方式——这真的很酷。所以事实证明，大脑中有所有这些不同的部分参与视觉。所以有一个专门负责处理运动的区域，那是耳朵后面这里。然后有一个完全不同的区域处理纹理——
Lightness, so how bright is something.
亮度，比如东西有多亮。
--orientation, shape. And in Daniel's brain, many of these areas were lighting up. Color and brightness, no action there. But motion, when they did that salad bowl in motion test, the motion area behind the ears started pumping with blood flow.
——方向、形状。在Daniel的大脑中，许多这些区域都在发光。颜色和亮度，没有反应。但运动，当他们做那个运动中的沙拉碗测试时，耳朵后面的运动区域开始泵入血液。
Very vigorously.
非常有力。
And orientation-- turns out there's sort of a grid for orientation in the brain. And she could watch as the salad bowl moved across those quadrants.
而且方向——事实证明大脑中有一种方向网格。她可以观察到沙拉碗穿过那些象限。
It was really robust, highly significant.
它是非常稳健的，高度显著。
All right, Miss Spiegel. So I know that sometimes neurology and neuroscience--
好的，Spiegel小姐。所以我知道有时神经学和神经科学——
Goes over my head?
超过了我的理解范围？
Or just sounds like a foreign language that you're not particularly interested in speaking.
或者只是听起来像是一门你不想讲的外语。
Uh-huh. Just land the plane for me. What does this mean?
嗯哼。帮我总结一下吧。这到底是什么意思？
What this work suggests is that you may not actually need eyes to see.
这项工作表明，你实际上可能根本不需要眼睛来“看见”。
I kind of feel like we've got to shout it from the rooftops. Come on.
我感觉我们必须在屋顶上大声喊出来。来吧。
Oh my god.
哦，天哪。
OK. You might not need eyes to see!
好的。你可能不需要眼睛就能看见！
Now, Lore is by no means the only person seeing this result. The idea first started coming up in the mid '90s, when a lab at Harvard saw that visual areas of the brain can be activated by sound and touch.
现在，Lore绝不是唯一看到这个结果的人。这个想法首先在90年代中期出现，当时哈佛大学的一个实验室发现大脑的视觉区域可以被声音和触觉激活。
Do I have to do it?
我必须做吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
You might not need eyes to see!
你可能不需要眼睛就能看见！
And since then, dozens of labs have been looking into just how nuanced and rich that visual imagery may be. So there's a guy at Berkeley, Santani Teng, who's been trying to determine the acuity of these images. You know, like an eye test-- how close to 20/20 are they?
从那时起，几十个实验室一直在研究这种视觉表象可能有多么细腻和丰富。所以伯克利有一个叫Santani Teng的家伙，他一直试图确定这些图像的敏锐度。你知道，就像视力测试——它们有多接近20/20？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And what he's found is that their 75% localization thresholds indicated spatial acuity as fine as 1.5 degrees of the subtended angle.
他发现他们75%的定位阈值显示空间敏锐度细致到1.5度角。
No!
不是吧！
It's true! I'll put it another way. He thinks their world looks a lot like your peripheral vision. So imagine that you're texting on your cellphone walking down the street. OK, you're looking at that screen. Now, what does the street look like to you?
这是真的！我换个说法。他认为他们的世界看起来很像你的周边视觉。所以想象一下你一边发短信一边走在街上。好的，你在看那个屏幕。那么，街道在你看来是什么样的？
You know, you can see people coming at you. You can see cars. You can see trees. But you couldn't read a sign. That, he thinks, is Daniel's world.
你知道，你能看到人向你走来。你能看到车。你能看到树。但你看不清牌子。他认为，那就是Daniel的世界。
I can honestly, honestly say that I do not feel blind.
我能诚实地，诚实地说，我不觉得我是盲人。
So what does Lore say about this? Does she think that the echolocators are actually seeing?
所以Lore是怎么说的？她认为回声定位者真的在“看见”吗？
Well--
嗯——
That's almost philosophical, isn't it?
那几乎是哲学层面的，不是吗？
Lore asks the only people on Earth who can know-- people who use to see. You know, is what they're experiencing comparable?
Lore询问了地球上唯一能知道的人——那些曾经看得见的人。你知道，他们的经历具有可比性吗？
Yeah, oh yeah.
是的，哦是的。
This is Brian Bushway, who you met briefly at the top of the show.
这是Brian Bushway，你在节目开头见过他。
So step right up!
所以快来！
I became totally blind at the age of 14.
我在14岁时完全失明了。
But once he learned echolocation--
但一旦他学会了回声定位——
Just [SNAP] like that!
就像[啪]那样！
--the world around him, although blurrier and colorless, appeared again.
——他周围的世界，虽然模糊且没有颜色，又再次出现了。
Things are real. I mean, it's as real as looking at it.
事物是真实的。我的意思是，这就像看着它一样真实。
Wait, wait, wait. So Lulu, does every blind person have this?
等等，等等，等等。所以Lulu，每个盲人都有这个吗？
No. And that's the thing-- Lore has looked at the brains of people who do not echolocate, and though there's definitely some activity in the visual cortex, it's simply not as active. Which brings me back to Daniel's teaching methods. The thing about echolocation is, yes, you can learn it when you get older. But it gets so much harder with age, which is why Daniel doesn't give a damn about making a little kid cry, because he thinks at the other end of those tears is sight.
不。这就是重点——Lore观察了那些不回声定位的人的大脑，虽然视觉皮层肯定有一些活动，但它根本没有那么活跃。这就把我带回了Daniel的教学方法。回声定位的事情是，是的，你可以在年龄较大时学会它。但随着年龄增长会变得非常困难，这就是为什么Daniel根本不在乎让小孩哭，因为他认为在那些眼泪的另一端是视力。
OK, off we go.
好的，我们出发吧。
So I finally got to see one of these training sessions in action. We went to see a five-year-old boy named Nathan Nip.
所以我终于能亲眼看到其中一个训练课程了。我们去见了一个叫Nathan Nip的五岁小男孩。
OK, so what we'll do then is we'll ask Nathan's mom about parks or some place that he doesn't know.
好的，所以我们要做的是问Nathan的妈妈关于公园或他不知道的地方。
Brian's with us too, actually. He's now one of Daniel's deputy teachers.
Brian也和我们在一起，实际上。他现在是Daniel的副老师之一。
He can click.
他会点击。
And part of the goal that day was to get Nathan out of his comfort zone. But the bigger part-- and really, what is often this other major part of what Daniel is trying to teach-- is to get the people around Nathan to back off.
那天部分目标是让Nathan走出他的舒适区。但更大的部分——实际上，通常是Daniel试图教授的另一部分主要工作——是让Nathan周围的人后退。
Hello?
喂？
Hi!
嗨！
So we go into the house.
所以我们进了房子。
I am five and a half, and Ashton's two.
我五岁半，Ashton两岁。
Daniel asks to hear Nathan's clicks.
Daniel要求听Nathan的点击声。
[TONGUE CLICKING]
[舌头点击声]
You have a nice smiley click.
你有很好、很开心的点击声。
And then we head out to a faraway park.
然后我们前往一个遥远的公园。
Where are we? Where do you think we are?
我们在哪里？你认为我们在哪里？
At the field!
在操场上！
At the field.
在操场上。
Ding, ding, ding. It's a sports field flanked by a really busy road.
叮，叮，叮。这是一个被非常繁忙的道路夹在中间的运动场。
Nathan? Nathan?
Nathan？Nathan？
And the idea is to make Nathan find his way around this park by himself.
目标是让Nathan自己找到穿过这个公园的路。
So we want to use our, [TONGUE CLICKING], our clicks. And we're going to explore what's around here in this park. Let's see if we can find anything, OK?
所以我们要用我们的，[舌头点击声]，我们的点击声。我们要探索这个公园周围有什么。让我们看看能不能找到什么，好吗？
Yeah.
好。
OK.
好的。
So he finds a soccer net.
所以他找到了一个足球网。
Yeah.
好的。
He tries to find a fence at one side of the park--
他试图找到公园一侧的围栏——
Well, you're-- yeah, we're in the bushes.
嗯，你在——是的，我们在灌木丛里。
--but gets a little turned around.
——但有点迷失方向。
Come back toward me. Nathan, come back toward me.
回到我这边。Nathan，回到我这边来。
And then it's time to find the edge of the road.
然后是时候找到道路的边缘了。
What noises do we hear right now?
我们现在听到什么声音？
Cars?
车？
Cars.
车。
So Brian tells Nathan to walk toward those cars.
所以Brian告诉Nathan向那些车走去。
And we'll all follow behind you.
我们将都在你身后跟着。
At this point, it's just me and the godmother and Brian.
此时，只有我和教母还有Brian。
Where's Ashton?
Ashton在哪里？
He's over there.
他在那边。
Everyone else is on the other side of the park.
其他所有人在公园的另一边。
Can we please go to him?
我们能去他那里吗？
No.
不行。
Why?
为什么？
Nathan is leading.
Nathan在带路。
Can I hear you click?
能让我听听你的点击声吗？
[TONGUE CLICKING].
[舌头点击声]。
And picture this-- I mean, this is, like, a little five-year-old boy with a tiny white cane--
想象一下——我的意思是，这就像一个小五岁男孩拿着一根细细的白手杖——
Kind of tapping his way towards oncoming traffic?
敲着路走向迎面而来的车辆？
Tapping his way toward oncoming traffic, which is a jarring sight. And the person closest to him is Brian, who is also blind.
敲着路走向迎面而来的车流，这是一个刺眼的景象。而离他最近的人是Brian，他也是盲人。
Listen out in front of you. Listen into the distance.
听你前面。听远方。
And he's getting closer and closer to the edge of the road. Four feet, three feet, and then--
他离道路边缘越来越近。四英尺，三英尺，然后——
[CAR APPROACHING]
[车辆临近]
[SILENCE]
[沉默]
--his godmother just shoots out and grabs him back. And Brian kind of noticeably flinched.
——他的教母冲出来把他拉了回来。而Brian明显地退缩了。
Let's try to stay, like, more  or less behind him.
让我们试着待在，大概在他后面。
Because while he completely understands why the godmother would reach out for Nathan, he said it is precisely that kind of moment that does the damage.
因为虽然他完全理解教母为什么要伸手去抓Nathan，但他说正是那种时刻造成了伤害。
Often sighted people will jump in a half a second too soon, and they rob the blind student from that learning moment. And that just keeps happening over and over again, and I think so many blind people's lives, they never get that moment of what it is to really have that self-confidence to trust your senses to know, oh, if I do use my cane properly and I am listening attentively to information around me, I'll be OK.
视力正常人通常会提前半秒跳出来，他们抢走了盲生学习的那个时刻。这种情况一直在发生，我认为在许多盲人的生活中，他们从没有过那种真正拥有自信去信任感官的时刻，去知道，噢，如果我正确使用手杖，并且专心地听周围的信息，我就没事。
I think part of the problem is that when we have eyes, we can see things coming from further away. The whole point is, like, when it's your cane and you're clicking, you catch edges at what appears like the last moment.
我认为问题的一部分在于，当我们有眼睛时，我们可以从更远的地方看到事物。关键在于，当你用手杖和点击时，你似乎在最后一刻才捕捉到边缘。
We don't need to go any farther. Why? Why don't we need to go any further?
我们不需要再走远了。为什么？为什么我们不需要再走远了？
'Cause there's cars.
因为有车。
Yeah, so it means the street's here.
是的，所以意味着街就在这里。
[TONGUE CLICKING].
[舌头点击声]。
Can I ask  you a question?
我能问你一个问题吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
What if you're a half-second too late?
如果晚了半秒怎么办？
Right.
对。
Because I think that probably a lot of parents-- I mean, the thing that keeps them reaching out well before the half-second before is kind of the specter of the half-second after.
因为我想很多父母——我的意思是，让他们在半秒之前就伸手阻拦的原因，某种程度上是半秒之后的幽灵。
So I think you grabbed him there.
所以我认为你刚才抓住了他。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的，是的。
And what was that moment like?
那个时刻是什么样的？
Well, this is exactly what Nathan's godmother brought up.
嗯，这正是Nathan教母提出的。
It is hard.
很难。
She understands the dangers of a half-second too early.
她理解提前半秒的危险。
He has to learn how to make that judgment.
他必须学会如何做出那个判断。
But at the end of the day, she is far more concerned about the dangers of the half-second too late.
但归根结底，她对晚了半秒的危险更加关心。
You don't really want to risk that.
你真的不想冒那个险。
Which brings me to possibly the biggest thing that Daniel is up against in his quest to change expectations-- love.
这就把我带到了Daniel在改变期望的追求中可能面临的最大阻力——爱。
You can't blame mom and dad for struggling and wanting to keep their child safe.
你不能责怪父母挣扎着想要保护他们的孩子安全。
This is Dan Norris again from the blindness organization in Vermont. And when we asked him if a change like the one Daniel's hoping for, a massive change in expectations, could actually take place, one of the main obstacles he brought up was love.
这是佛蒙特州盲人组织的Dan Norris。当我们问他，像Daniel希望的那样发生改变、即期望发生大规模改变是否真的可能时，他提出的主要障碍之一就是爱。
It's very hard as a parent with a child who's visually impaired to let go.
作为一名视力受损孩子的父母，放手真的很难。
Even when the expectations for that kid are high, he said love can get in the way.
即使对孩子的期望很高，他说爱也会挡路。
Those parents, they want to keep their child safe. They want their child to not suffer. And that's very noble but holds the kids back.
那些父母，他们想保护他们的孩子安全。他们不想让他们的孩子受苦。这非常高尚，但也束缚了孩子。
So in 10 years in the field, how many kids on bikes have you seen, blind kids on bikes?
所以在这行10年，你见过多少骑自行车的孩子，骑自行车的盲童？
Blind kids on bikes? I have seen about five.
骑自行车的盲童？我大约见过五个。
That's actually pretty good.
那其实相当不错。
Yeah, I think that we are seeing society begin to change.
是的，我认为我们看到社会开始改变。
But when he thinks about the sheer volume of love, brimming in every household on every schoolyard and every street corner--
但当他想到每一个家庭、每一个校园、每一个街角涌动的巨大爱意——
Are we going to get there any time soon as a nation? Um, no. I don't think so.
我们作为一个国家很快能达到那个目标吗？嗯，不。我不这么认为。
And this gets us finally to what may have been Daniel's one true superpower.
这最终把我们带到了Daniel可能拥有的唯一真正的超级能力。
What most people find to be the meaning of life absolutely creeps me out.
大多数人发现是人生意义的东西，绝对让我毛骨悚然。
Daniel is 49 and has never been with a partner. And he finds the whole idea of physical intimacy--
Daniel 49岁了，从未有过伴侣。他发现关于亲密的整个概念——
Unsettling.
令人不安。
We had finally reached the end of our hike, the place Daniel wanted to take me.
我们终于到达了徒步的终点，Daniel想带我来的地方。
Is this, like, awesome?
这很棒，是吧？
Yeah.
是的。
It was a huge old oak tree, miles from civilization, that Daniel said was one of his favorite spots on Earth.
那是一棵巨大的老橡树，远离文明，Daniel说这是他地球上最喜欢的地方之一。
OK.
好的。
And so we climbed up it together.
于是我们一起爬了上去。
Let's see where I would go.
看看我要去哪。
20 feet, 30 feet, maybe 40 feet.
20英尺，30英尺，也许40英尺。
You're very high!
你真高！
And it was there in the branches that he told me he's never really been one for love.
正是在树枝上，他告诉我他从来都不是那种追求爱的人。
I was never that interested in closeness as a kid. I wasn't really a lap-sitter. I didn't like holding hands. I didn't really like hugs.
我小时候对亲密关系没什么兴趣。我不是那种会坐在别人腿上的孩子。我不喜欢牵手。我不喜欢拥抱。
He even used to have nightmares about it.
他甚至过去常做关于这些的噩梦。
A child's mind will turn things into very ghoulish, ghastly, deeply unsettling, spooky things.
孩子的脑子会把事情变成非常丑陋、可怕、令人深感不安、毛骨悚然的东西。
Like what? Like, what would be a nightmare about--
比如什么？比如，噩梦会是什么关于——
There were two.
有两个。
In one, a hand chased after him.
在一个噩梦里，一只手追着他。
And then the other thing were the plastic arms that want to sort engulf and unfold and just kind of take you in to themselves.
还有另一件事是塑料手臂，它们想要那种吞噬、展开，并把你带入它们内部。
He's not sure where this comes from. He wonders if it could have been the surgeries he had as a tiny boy or from the way his parents raised him. Or maybe he just always was that way.
他不确定这从何而来。他纳闷这是否来自他很小时做过的手术，或者来自他父母抚养他的方式。也许他一直就是那样。
Who knows?
谁知道呢？
And while he's not suggesting that you need this quality to become independent, when he looks back, he wonders if this may have been one of the things that protected him from the debilitating effects of low expectations. Because unlike the rest of us, when those arms reached out for him, he never once had any desire to fall back into them.
虽然他没说你需要这种品质才能变得独立，但当他回首往事时，他纳闷这是否是保护他免受低期望削弱影响的事情之一。因为不像我们其他人，当那些手臂向他伸过来时，他从未有过落入其中的渴望。
Everything that happens in your life has its effect.
你生命中发生的每一件事都有其影响。
That's his mom again, Paulette.
那是他妈妈，Paulette。
Has its effect.
有其影响。
And you don't think it's that Daniel became this way because he was in some way neglected or because it was too hard? Is there any part of you that thinks you went too far in terms of letting him be?
你不认为Daniel变成这样是因为他在某种程度上被忽视了，或者因为那太难了？有没有一部分的你认为你在让他放手这件事上走得太远了？
No. No. He's happy.
没有。没有。他很高兴。
Totally happy.
非常高兴。
We sat there for a while, watching the afternoon slip away.
我们坐在那里一会儿，看着下午溜走。
Listen to how quiet it is.
听听这里有多安静。
And suddenly I got that pang you get when you realize it's getting dark, and you are far, far from civilization. And that was followed by another pang that it literally didn't matter, because he'd be the one leading us out.
突然，当我意识到天快黑了，而我们离文明极其遥远时，我感受到那种刺痛。紧接着又是一种刺痛，即那根本不重要，因为会带我们走出这里的人是他。
[TONGUE CLICKING] That's amazing.
[舌头点击声] 那太神奇了。
Yeah.
是的。
[TONGUE CLICKING]
[舌头点击声]
[MUSIC - "BATMAN THEME" BY NEIL HEFTI]
[音乐 - Neil Hefti的《蝙蝠侠主题曲》]
Lulu Miller and Alix Spiegel of Invisibilia , the new public radio program and podcast. Lots of public radio stations, hundreds of them, have picked up the show. So check your local station's website to see if they might be carrying it and when. Or to get the podcast, go to npr.org/invisibilia.
Lulu Miller和Alix Spiegel，来自《无形》，这档新的公共广播节目和播客。许多公共广播电台，数百家，都已经购买了这个节目。所以看看你当地电台的网站，看看他们是否播放，以及什么时候播放。或者要获取播客，请访问 npr.org/invisibilia。
Our program was produced today by Sean Cole and myself, with Stefanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. NPR's Anne Gudenkauf is the editor in Invisibilia . She edited today's story. Production help today from JP Dukes and Simon Adler. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help today from Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef.
我们的节目今天由Sean Cole和我制作，参与制作的还有Stefanie Foo、Chana Joffe-Walt、Sarah Koenig、Miki Meek、Jonathan Menjivar、Brian Reed、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike。我们的资深制作人是Julie Snyder。NPR的Anne Gudenkauf是《无形》的编辑。她编辑了今天的故事。今天的制作协助来自JP Dukes和Simon Adler。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的办公室经理。Adrianne Mathiowetz负责我们的网站。Elna Baker为我们的节目搜寻故事。今天的研究协助来自Christopher Swetala。音乐协助来自Damien Graef。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He says, sure, yes, it's true. He was found wearing a bathing suit standing out in the middle of the street in the middle of winter, in the middle of night, holding a quarter million dollars in cash that was not his.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》通过公共广播交换平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。和往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他说，当然，是的，是真的。人们发现他穿着泳衣站在冬夜街道中央，手里拿着不是他的四分之一百万美元现金。
But that could happen to anyone. It can happen to anyone.
但这可能发生在任何人身上。它可能发生在任何人身上。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是Ira Glass。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。